und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt der mann
der die führenden köpfe der
kanzlerpartei morgen zu einer
vertraulichen klausur zusammen beruft
und da dürfte es auch um die gerade
gehörte kritik gehen ich begrüße den
spd-parteivorsitzenden lars klingbeil
da klingt die deutschen unterlagen in
washington waren deutschland würde dort
mittlerweile als unzuverlässiger partner
bezeichnet der seit jahren ungeklärte
russland kurz der spd wird
offensichtlich zunehmend zur belastung
dieser krise was muss ihre morgige
klausur leisten um dieser kritik künftig
zu entgehen
also erstmal will ich das einordnen wir
kommen morgen zu einem routine treffen
zusammen ich bin als parteivorsitzender
zuständig für internationale fragen und
ich will mich mit ein paar führenden
köpfen aus regierungspartei aus fraktion
beraten weil in der tat mitten in europa
droht ein krieg und das gilt jetzt darum
in der regierung aber auch in der partei
und fraktion alle maßnahmen zu
unternehmen damit der krieg mitten in
europa zwei flugstunden von berlin
abgewandt werden kann darum geht es und
über diese frage werden wir morgen
intensiv sprechen aber die linie der spd
ist ja vertrauter maßen nicht klar
altkanzler schröder beispielsweise wird
ausgerechnet der ukraine säbelrasseln
vor distanzieren sie sich davon
ich kann ihnen sagen die linie der spd
ist sehr klar wir nehmen absolut ernst
was da passiert das ist eine dramatische
lage mitten in europa wir sagen sehr
klar als parteiführung auch der
bundeskanzler das betont die eskalation
die wir gerade erleben die geht von
russland aus und deswegen ist auch klar
alle optionen liegen auf dem tisch
sollte russland die territoriale
integrität der ukraine angreifen und
jetzt gilt es aber darum jedes gespräch
zu führen jeden tisch zu nutzen an denen
man sich setzen kann um einen
diplomatischen ausweg aus dieser krise
zu suchen und krieg zu verhindern da
sind olaf scholz saskia esken und ich
völlig klar das ist der weg der spd wir
nehmen gerne ratschläge entgegen und das
ist auch völlig okay wenn andere sich in
die debatte einmischen aber die die
verantwortung für die partei tragen die
sind klar und deutlich und
unmissverständlich der ratschlag ihres
vorgängers sigmar gabriel heute lautet
eine offene diskussion über
waffenlieferungen 2014 hat die
bundesregierung ja
unter spd beteiligung schon einmal
waffen in ein spannungsgebiet geliefert
für die kurden im irak für die ukraine
aber machen sie keine ausnahme
ich habe eine prinzipielle überzeugung
dass es nichts bringt wenn wir waffen
liefern und gerade in der jetzigen
situation würde dazu führen dass wir
eine tür aufstoßen die wir vielleicht
nicht mehr zu bekommen es geht gerade
darum mit der russischen seite
diplomatische gespräche zu führen wie
wir krieg mitten in europa abwenden
können und wir müssen uns genau
überlegen was es bedeutet wenn wir
gerade täglich eine verschärfung der
lage leben wenn worte täglich schärfer
werden wenn aber auch aktionen schärfer
werden und ich glaube dass die
waffenlieferung ein völlig falsches
signal während das würde nicht dazu
führen dass wir zu einer diplomatischen
entspannung der situation kommen wir
unterstützen die ukraine wirtschaftlich
wir unterstützen sie diplomatisch das
normandie format wieder aufleben zu
lassen ist ein ganz wichtiger schritt
also deutschland unternimmt viel aber
waffenlieferungen sind der falsche weg
selbst wenn wir selbst nicht liefern als
bundesregierung ist möchte haubitzen an
die ukraine liefern aber weil die aus
ddr beständen sind braucht es die
zustimmung der bundesregierung
die aber wurde bisher nicht erteilt sind
sie für eine freigabe
da gibt es mechanismen in der
bundesregierung führt jetzt geprüft
werden aber nochmal meine grundsätzliche
skepsis für waffenlieferungen in
krisengebiete habe ich gerade deutlich
gemacht es geht jetzt darum frieden zu
organisieren da geht was die sich reiche
da geht es um diplomatie da geht es auch
darum sich an einen tisch zu setzen ich
halte nichts von waffenlieferungen in
krisengebiete egal aus welchem land sie
kommen nun sagen die usa sie verstärken
ihre truppen in osteuropa die briten
bieten jetzt an heute ihre truppen zu
verdoppeln sind das in ihren augen
riskante konflikt verstärkungen oder die
richtige abschreckung
das sind ja vorgänger die innerhalb der
nato auch besprochen wurden auch
deutschland hat ja an der nato ostflanke
truppen stationiert wir werden jetzt in
litauen in den nächsten tagen das
fünfjährige bestehen auch von truppen
dort haben also das sind alles vorgänge
die in der nato verabredet sind aber
nochmal jetzt geht es darum dass im un
sicherheitsrat das im normandie normal
dass unter den außenministern das im
nato-russland-rat dass in all diesen
orten gespräche geführt werden ich bin
mir sicher wir können eine kriegerische
auseinandersetzung mit in europa
abwenden darauf sollten sich jetzt alle
politischen akteure konzentrieren hier
klicken herzlichen dank für das gespräch
sehr gerne